make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so with our x-men playlist that
you'll find down in the description ah
that playlist is designed to teach you
everything you need to know about the
x-men right so like if you decide you
want to go pick up house and powers of X
you're not gonna be left blinded right
here to come be like okay I can watch
the videos in this playlist and
basically understand everything I need
to know but one of the things I told you
guys is that that playlist was gonna be
growing constantly you were constantly
gonna be adding things to it it's more
or less kind of like an x-men
encyclopedia and so in this video I want
to talk about telepathy
now the other benefit to doing this is
that not only does it of course expand
the exponents a clippie dia but you can
actually use this to basically
understand telepathy from anybody else
right so like Doctor Strange Scarlet
Witch any other character that exists
out there even the mine stone with
regards to the Infinity stones we'll
talk about that here in a second because
that's a really interesting scenario it
actually is really more of a cheat code
than anything else but when it comes to
till up at the Marvel Comics this is
really a byproduct for two concepts the
first is the astral plane and the second
or thoughts trees so for this video
we're gonna use the example of Charles
Xavier of the x-men right he's probably
the most popular telepath that exists
the Marvel Comics we can use Jean Grey
too if we wanted to you but Professor X
is the leader of the x-men most people
know about it right and so because of
this let's say for example that
Professor X is sitting at a restaurant
drinking a cup of coffee and he sees a
guy on a street corner and he says I
wonder what that guy is thinking how
does that work how does Charles Xavier
go from wondering what that guy's
thinking to knowing what that guy's
thinking okay so let's imagine that all
these areas people out there everybody
around the world has these kind of misty
streams that lead out of their brain up
to a portal about ten feet above their
heads and then they just kind of go into
that portal that portal leads to a place
called the astral plane and the astral
plane is a dimension that exists out
there and every single universe has its
own version of the astral plane but the
astral plane is a is a dimension that
exists out there that basically houses
what's called ectoplasm
now ectoplasm as it exists in Marvel
Comics I mean I can't really speak to
how its portrayed in the real world but
in terms of Marvel Comics ectoplasm is
more or less kind of like a gelatinous
sort of substance right so if you could
physically go into the astral plane and
then you saw a rock you would be you
would try to touch the rock pass your
hand through it and it would almost be
kind of like gelatinous or a little bit
misty but not truly solid right not like
your desk or like somebody's hand or
something like that and so inside this
astral plane or the conscious and
subconscious thoughts of all all beings
in existence across the universe right
like every single beam that could have
conscious thought or subconscious
thought is essentially sentient or even
non-sentient ah will be able to access
the the astral plane right that's
basically how that works now their
thoughts simply radiate in there
telepaths are aware of the astral plane
for the average person walking around
they don't know about it right they have
no idea what it is they didn't even see
that stream of thoughts coming out of
their head they walk around and see the
world the exact same way you do but for
Charles Xavier while he doesn't really
see the mind streams coming out of their
head what he can do is he can basically
read what's going on in the astral plane
now how a person accesses this and what
impact the astral plane has on them is
really relative to how developed their
powers are like if we if we say Charles
Xavier first developed its telepathy
when that first happened he started
hearing a whole bunch of different
thoughts at the same time and he
couldn't really control it why because
of the fact that what his mind was
accessing the astral plane he couldn't
discern between different people's
thoughts
he couldn't basically say I only want to
hear this one guy's thoughts I don't
want to hear everybody's I only want to
hear that one guy his brain couldn't do
that because he didn't know how instead
he had basically opened his mind to the
astral plane when his telepathy
activated and the result was that all
these thoughts came pouring yet and so
when a person has telepathy their mind
is always open to the astral plane they
can never close it off they can never
shut off their mind to the astral plane
that's part of their powers right so
it's like it's like if Cyclops could
never close his eyes right I mean that's
really how that works his optic beams
would just emanate forever because this
energy from a different dimension in
terms of Cyclops is concussive blacks
and so a person with telepathy their
minds always open to the astral plane
the idea of learning how to use their
telepathy is basically being able to
discern between different things in the
astral plane to go in there and say I
only want to hear the thoughts of this
guy on the street corner not everybody
in the entire city that's where the hard
work comes from that's why it is when
Jean Grey first developed her powers she
couldn't control them Charles Xavier who
basically put a mental block which is to
say he put a block between her mind in
the astral plane as opposed to just
shutting her mind off to the astral
plane it can't be done and so here's the
question if Charles Xavier wants to make
that guy think something how does he do
that okay so let's say this guy on the
street corner is thinking I wonder what
it's like to be a dog what would happen
is Charles Xavier zs-- mind and yo being
open to the astral plane his mind would
basically read through and it would it
would isolate that guy's thought pattern
I that guys thought stream as it's
radiating into the astral plane Charles
Xavier would find it located and then he
would read it and he would say okay so
this guy's thoughts dream says he wants
to know what it's like to be a dog all
right that's how Charles
they reprints up on it now the question
becomes what if Charles Xavier wanted to
make that guy believe he was a dog right
the guy says I wonder what it's like to
be a dog and Xavier says okay let's make
that happen how does that work what
would happen is Charles Xavier
his owns command believe you're a dog
would leave his brain
travel into the astral plane and down
the thought stream of that guy right I
mean a way out is a way in so if he has
thoughts leaving his brain and makes
sense you can have thoughts into his
brain and so Charles Xavier thoughts
will go down that thought stream that
guy has it would enter into his mind and
it would dominate all other thoughts and
his soul belief would be that he's a dog
he would believe it wholeheartedly
that's how Charlie Xavier telepathy
works now here's the question do all
forms of telepathy work that way no and
the reason why is because they're not
powerful enough right like a person a
person who can basically place a thought
in the mind of another person has to
have telepathy that's powerful enough to
override that person's thought and so if
so if Charles Xavier is like if he's
like three years out from first
discovering his patters right so he
discovered he was a telepath three years
later he wants to put a thought in the
mind of a person he wouldn't really be
able to do that because of the fact that
his powers are so new and he's not
strong enough he's basically not able to
force that thought into that person's
head time will come with enough training
and enough exercise where he can do it
but at the moment he wouldn't have been
able to do it and so that's really how
that works right it's just kind of
sitting thoughts down the stream of a
person and into their brain and then
making them believe a certain thing now
here's the next question
what if we're talking about like a city
block right like what if Charles Xavier
says this guy wants to know what it's
like to be a dog I wonder what everybody
else is thinking he would say okay let's
look at this entire city block and what
he would do is the exact same thing
except he would read the thoughts dreams
of everybody in the city block and maybe
they're all thinking I wonder what it's
like to be a dog so he would say okay
then let's make them all dogs and the
exact same process would happen except
it would be expanded to a city block all
their minds will be dominated by Xavier
and they would all believed that they
were dogs now the cool thing about this
is that this brings another question how
do people do things like shield their
mind from telepaths how do people do
things like create telepathic illusions
like how does all this work it comes
down to those two things accessing the
thoughts room of a person through the
astral plane and then placing a thought
in their head right that's really how
all that stuff works
that's what telepathy is so powerful
because maybe Charles Xavier does not
put a thought in this guy's head that
he's a dog maybe you've put the thought
in this guy's head that everybody else
are dogs and so this guy bull his brain
believes
that every everybody else her daughter's
right because whatever the brain
controls he controls the brain controls
the five senses and so he can basically
make this guy believe everything right
so he can say this guy wants to know
what it's like to be a dog I'm gonna
deny him that but I am gonna make him
believe that everybody in the city of
Manhattan or dogs and so sending that
command into his head the command would
be everyone around you are dogs and so
when he walks around he walks up to a
person to his sense of sight sees a dog
his sense of smell smells a dog his
sense of hearing hears that dog bark so
on and so forth his brain truly believes
that because it's brain doesn't know
that it's been told that it's brain just
believes that that's true because in all
reality he's been commanded by that now
this also begs the question of doing
things like creating psychic shields
right I mean we talked about that with
regards to Jean Grey there's more or
less creating a wall between the astral
plane and a person's telepathy it more
or less artificially cuts them off from
like all the voices that would be there
or being able to access any other voice
now the sooner you start getting into
the hierarchy of telepaths right like a
person who's a sufficiently powerful
telepath can actually shut off the
telepathic abilities of someone else
right so like with the case of Professor
X and Jean Grey because she was much
much weaker than Charles Xavier was and
because of the fact that he knew were
telepathy was over overwhelming her what
he did is he created a blog so she
basically couldn't access her telepathy
but if it's someone like a villain
someone like strife the evil clone of
cable from the future who in turn faces
off against some weaker telepath that's
out there in turn he could do the exact
same thing he could actually show off
their powers and depending on what it is
that he wants them to do he could
actually do things like like during the
there was a story where he fought Hope
Summers who was a mutant that could copy
the powers of everybody else but because
of the fact that she wasn't really
familiar with telepathy I mean she was
but she wasn't nearly as adept as if
strife was strife basically used the
thought stream in the astral plane to
essentially send a thought into Hope
Summers head take my powers like absorb
my powers and then travel to the x-men
and explode like a bomb and that's what
she did right I mean she didn't kill
them all but that's exactly what she did
this is exactly how that works right
this is how these various things happen
if an individual has an X gene in their
body and that X team has not been
activated right so say Charles Xavier is
sitting on that street corner and he
uses telepathy and he basically takes
control of the guy's brain and analyzes
his body and realizes that he has ID
telekinesis but just simply hasn't
activated yet then what Charlie jr. can
do is he can dominate the brain and say
activate the X gene for telekinesis and
the guys got telekinetic
telepathy is a very very very strong
power
there are telepaths out there who are
powerful enough to dominate the minds of
everybody on earth they're telepaths out
there that are powerful enough to
dominate the Wills of like a person
who's a reality woman right like
Franklin Richards as a little kid when
he was really really young and his
powers weren't really developed yet a
person who was powerful enough that
sufficiently powerful telepaths say for
example strife could show up and then
dominate the mind of Franklin Richards
and Franklin Richards wouldn't really
know how to counteract that because he
wasn't really adept enough with his
powers in order to beat him off using
something like that strife could in turn
say okay
so like Franklin Richards has
reality-warping powers I'm gonna make
him my weapon so he's gonna dominate the
mind of Franklin Richards and say now
I'm gonna control your powers right I
mean it depends on how it is it you want
to do it usually mine domination does
not work for the long term that's a
reason why during the onslaught saw that
onslaught actually appeared to Franklin
Richards as a friend as opposed to just
like dominating its market right because
with somebody like Franklin as a kid
with reality-warping powers his
abilities are very very spontaneous and
you never really know what's gonna
happen
telepathy is one of the coolest versions
of powers that are out there and there's
a lot of other things that go into it
like people for example who are who have
clear avoidance you have a measure of
telepathy these are individuals that can
basically go into the astral plane and
then essentially see everything that's
going on right now and then say okay
like given everything that's happening
what's the most likely outcome and then
actually be able to kind of break the
timestream to a degree and be able to
see into the future now it's usually
pretty murky if the only real way to
know the future is to be a time traveler
and actually go there it's the only real
surefire way to know exactly what's
going to happen moment by moment in a
particular time period but let's move
away from like using powers in the
traditional sense and let's focus on the
mind stone okay the mind stone is more
or less like a cheat code when it comes
to telepathy right because it allows you
to read and dominate the minds of all
beings in existence regardless of what
their level of power is right so that
using the Infinity Gauntlet or using the
mind stone Thanos could know if he
wanted to he could dominate the minds of
all beings in existence including the
cosmic entities the only being he could
not dominate would be the Living
Tribunal right because this just is
beyond the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet a being who is sufficiently
beyond the power in the Infinity
Gauntlet would not be able to be
dominated right so like the Mark II of
death or somebody like that whose power
transcends into the multiverse the
molecule molecule man Owen Reese any one
of the beyonders different characters
like that but using the mind stone is a
very dangerous thing and that
why when Thanos got it he didn't
actually use it to dominate the minds of
all beings in existence or read the
minds of all beings across the universe
because it would be overwhelmed but I
miss that going from zero to sixty in
the smallest amount of time after zero
it would be astronomical and he'd just
be sitting there you use the mind stone
and suddenly you just met with all
thoughts from all beings conscious and
subconscious across the entirety of the
universe it would drive you insane you
could go into a catatonic state because
your mind wouldn't know how to do how to
handle that you have to work your way up
to it and so that's why it's such a
capable thing now because of the fact of
the mind stone is kind of a cheat code
what it does is basically sort of guide
you through right so it allows you to
automatically kind of discern different
thoughts and really sort of like treat
you like you you we were at depth right
I mean that's this that's kind of how it
acts but that's that's the difference is
the mind stone you have to have a mind
that's cubed of using it and at the same
time have a - capable of discerning
thoughts I mean it gets kind of murky
just because of the fact there's some
contradictory information there but
again that's more or less how to love
with you works this really just thought
streams emanating from the minds of all
beings that can have a conscious or
subconscious thought and then dominating
those based on what you want to do and
the expansion or at least how much of an
area of effect you have with your
telepathy is relative to how powerful
you are the more you push your powers
the more your mind has to adapt and
basically learn to you so it's alep
athenian slow at the end in Marvel
Comics is kind of weird and kind of
wonky but it's a cool concept and it's
really really a probably I think one of
the more interesting powers because of
all the things that you can do with it
ah Benny said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end hopefully you guys
are a lot more knowledgeable about how
to love if he works hopefully you know a
lot more if you guys are new here to
come this explain where you guys took
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like there we go I
forgot my own outro and I will catch you
all later Bruce
[Music]